Europe's new external border control
system part of its response to the
influx of refugees and migrants on its
southern flank is taking shape including
an element vital to securing EU external
borders and protecting the Schengen zone
the European border and coast guard at
the heart of it is strengthening the
existing Border Agency Frontex allowing
member states whose borders come under
pressure to call in rapidly deployable
multinational support teams I said Renee
Jones incapacitate mississauga Dakota
yes immobilize a blue immediate mollusk
anita mambo on fella demondo AP KO SI la
la la possibilité de la cabeza de ho de
de que le material trapeze mo pas
pouvoir lousy traffic as a ripe old
[ __ ] no neutrons member states will
still manage their external borders day
to day but if they refuse to accept
support in extreme cases it can be
forced on them the agency will also have
a greater role in returning migrants to
their home countries but as executors of
decisions by member states it's hoped
the agency will start in September 2016
and be fully functional by November the
speed of its establishment a measure of
the e use urgency in dealing with the
migration crisis